vous avez entendu ce que j'ai dit hier
j'ai dit qu'à on reprendrait pas les
missions normales
le 11 mai on est en train de voir
d'autres possibilités j'espère pouvoir
vous retrouver quand même un peu loose
mais voilà peut-être dans une autre
configuration
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi je
pense que tant qu'il n'y a pas vraiment
je vous dis dessus de 2,2 voilà je vous
dis qu'on n'est pas sûr voilà qu'on peut
être qu'on fait voilà des confiné et
qu'on peut faire une émission en plateau
avec du public etc
je vois pas l'intérêt de faire tes pmp
un sou tpm paix dans un sou plateau avec
personne
franchement voilà moi je vais pas envie
de voyager j'ai pas envie de faire ça et
j'ai pas envie de faire prendre des
risques à des gens mêmes avouent
d'ailleurs et surtout à vous parce que
vous êtes les plus proches de moi et les
plus proches entre vous pour vraiment un
truc qui ferait qui serait pourri et je
n'ai pas du tout envie de vous faire
prendre de risques pour l'instant ça se
passe très bien comme ça mais on fera
une autre formule bien sûr le 11 mai si
ça déconfite vraiment si c'est un
premier déconfinement mais on fera pas
une formule voilà avec tout le monde
avec tous les techniciens avec plein de
cadreurs avec un réalisateur
voilà la non franchement on fera pas ça
donc ça c'est sûr et certain qu'est ce
que vous en pensez valérie franchement
c'est très très responsable de table de
votre part parce que je vois la santé
d'abord et avant tout et en même temps
évidemment il faut qu'on continue à
divertir les gens et les amuser et je
suis certaine que vous trouverez une
façon soit dans la configuration
actuelle soit une autre mais vraiment
sûr que ces neuf voilà c'est vous qui
avez raison il n'y a pas de certitudes
on continue et on a oui on y arrive vous
êtes arrivée des premières études et
trouver une solution pour continuer à
divertir les gens sans prendre de risque
sanitaire pour les uns et pour les
autres y compris les techniciens y
compris les maxi tueuse des coiffeurs
etc
donc moi je trouve que c'est nous qui la
bat gilles question pensez vous avez une
vocation à vous également chez vous je
trouve qu'à une exemplarité de ce que
vous avez fait moi tout le monde me le
dit dès le début vous avez appliqué les
consignes le confinement chez vous avez
donné une âme un style à cette émission
machecoul qu'ils font pour continuer sur
la même logique protection avant tout
rester proche des gens vous faites très
bien moi je suis pour que ça continue
alors j'ai vu des gens aussi qu'il
comparait les audiences bien sûr de tpm
paix aux audiences de ce soir tu vas pas
je vous dis les audiences elles sont
folles de ce soir shebab agrément on
aurait cru faire plus de 800 mille
téléspectateurs voilà c'est incroyable
mais voilà ce encore des balades et des
journalistes qui c'est qui ferez mieux
en ce moment de pau
c'est mine de rien à tout ce qui se
passe et essayer d'aider les gens plutôt
que d'écrire des torchons voilà pour
essayer de faire du clic mais ils
essaient de vivre mine de rien parce que
tous ces gens qui écrivent un mini rien
que ce soit télérama que personne ne lit
qui sera certainement mourir que ce soit
voilà les inrocks aussi qu'ils vont
certainement mourir que ce soit pure
médias que personne ne va consulter
voilà qui sont et qui font trois fois
moins aux quatre fois moins que jean
marc morandini gardiano forcément ils
essaient de vivre et limite je leur
envoie même pas ils essayent voilà deux
je vous dit d'essayer de tirer les
marrons du feu sur notre dos et essayer
de faire des clics sur notre dos mais
bon on s'en fout on leur en veux pas en
ce moment on n'en veut à personne
voilà on essaie d'être dans la
solidarité castaldi non mais juste et
vrai que belle façon de façon très
égoïste mais ma femme est enceinte est
sûr que si on devait aller tous son
plateau je vous dis franchement série
les vous le savez on ne naît pas
l'ensemble
moi je prendrais pas le risque d'aller
avec vous mais je sais qu'on a tous été
prudent pour risquer de ramener le virus
et la légende de mettre en danger ma
femme
comme je vous dis très franchement mes
enfants le 11 mai je suis pas du tout
certaine est envoyé à l'école parce que
j'adore c'est évidemment à mon foyer
voilà c'est tout et c'est très bien de
faire comme ça et ça marche très bien et
encore une fois c'est vrai c'est à
l'aube à basse et pathé pmp ça n'a
échappé à personne sauf aux cons qu'ils
écrivent mathieu à moi je subisse par
terre j'ai parce que c'est à partir du
11 mai on a le droit c'est à dire que
les spécialistes et que le gouvernement
considère qu'on ne prend plus de risques
non donc maintenant il ya un moment il
faudrait m et puis si tout le monde
reprend c'est tabou 28 minutes mal et
hollandais mais coûte mais pas que
mathieu y sont déjà ils ont déjà repris
quelques points comptent leurs prix les
rivages effet qu'il serait arrêté
ils ont jamais arrêter surtout son
plateau riche soit 28 minutes tournée on
est je vais te dire je suis actionnaire
de la boîte qui produit 28 minutes donc
je sais que voilà je te le dis ils ont
repris que ce soit quotidien ils ont
repris que ce soit c'est à vous ça
change pratiquement rien eu leurs
émissions c'est exactement la même et si
eux et moi je les ai déjà dit et je leur
jette pas la pierre ils font ce qu'ils
veulent anne-sophie voilà anne elisabeth
lemoine islam énormément voilà et en
plus
pierre antoine capton leurs producteurs
c'est vraiment un super pote à moi mais
je vous dis je lui ai dit on a eu cette
discussion
chacun fait ce qu'il veut eux ils disent
qu'ils veulent continuer en plateau et
prendre peut-être des risques ou pas de
risque peut-être que ces outils ont
raison peut-être qu'ils prennent aucun
chat qu'un fait ce qu'il veut quotidien
aussi libre et est resté en plateau nous
c'est pas notre cas nous aujourd'hui je
me vois pas revenir
tout et me dire voilà que peut-être un
chroniqueur ou d'autres va va rattraper
le coronavirus hugo vide parce qu'il est
venu sur le plateau voilà oui valérie
oui par ailleurs notre émission tlp
votre émission civile c'est une émission
d'humeur avec du public qui sent le
public qui l'a même pas de rêve nous
c'est un show ben voilà c'est comme si
nagui qui faisait n'oubliez pas les
paroles sans son projet tu vois pas bien
sûr ils sont musique ccc narbonne ce
sera mieux
non non non c'est un carton et allagui
et nagui il ferait 3 nagui pour te
calmer mon chéri qui fait deux fois les
audiences de tf1 avec un best-of c'est
incroyable on n'y fait plus de castillon
tous les jours tf1 ils sont à deux
millions et prennent une norme rousse
nagui fait un énorme carton c'est
incroyable les audiences de nagui sophie
cost non mais c'est vrai que en fait
aujourd'hui on vient un peu tous au jour
le jour et je suis d'accord avec
benjamin c'est ça c'est vrai qu'on vit
au jour le jour où l'un mais c'est vrai
on ne sait pas chaque jour on découvre
de nouvelles choses n'y a aucune
certitude sur vous avez eu le courage et
l'aplomb de montrer une certaine forme
d'exemplarité et vous pouvez pas répéter
sans cesse
restez chez vous si vous ne le faites
pas vous vous même en fait donc ce que
vous faites et est logique c'est
cohérent ça a du sens et pour l'heure
des temps moi je suis ravi de vous
suivre comme ça moi je moi je vous
dirais puis ce 11 mai on sait pas du
tout où on a dit le 11 mai les mecs
c'est pas parce que le 11 mai tu vas
pouvoir me sortir
vous nous voyez on va nous faire avoir
faire l'émission avec des masques et des
illégaux on essaie ni n'importe quoi
donc voilà et voilà chacun fait ce qu'il
veut comme j'ai dit à la télé mais non
on prendra pas le risque voilà dalle en
plateau mais je vais vous proposer
certainement autre chose vous verrez on
en train de travailler sur une formule
entre 19 20 avec vous les chroniqueurs
et sur une formule entre 20 et 21 et on
n'en va peut-être vous proposer un très
très gros jeu quand je vous dirais c'est
un très gros jeu voilà pour un jour et
ça on est en train de travailler là
dessus mais ça risque d'être très très
fort